wir haben ein problem wie sie von der
heute schon wir kommen nicht rein frau
kanzlerin haben sie vielleicht die
möglichkeit uns mitzunehmen
[Musik]
der heute show wollten übrigens mal im
foyer des bundestages bei den
abgeordneten nachfragen warum die
debattenkultur so auf den hund gekommen
so und jetzt kommt dann hat uns der
pressesprecher des bundestages und ich
will hier keine namen nennen aber es ist
dr ernst hebecker mitgeteilt die heute
show darf nicht mehr im bundestag drehen
denn was wir machen sah ja ich zitiere
keine politisch parlamentarische
berichterstattung
ich möchte dass hier nur gut wenn es von
herzen kommt ja gut dann lassen was drin
ja ich weiß was was machen wir denn
sonst hier außer politische
berichterstattung ohne scheiß jetzt
jeder darf drehen im bundestag kika
dreht im bundestag bauer sucht frau
dreht im bundestag
aber wir dürfen nicht rein das wollen
wir doch mal sehen
ralf kabelka bitte alle dürfen da rein
sogar andrea nahles bloß wir nicht und
ich sage das darf nicht sein
[Musik]
tatsächlich es ist kein reinkommen in
den deutschen bundestag wir sind die
vierte gewalt
klasse meinungsfreiheit in gefahr auch
die demokratie wenn sie dazu sehen macht
ihn aber nicht und holten sich ronja
kann man sie bestechen
sämtliche versuche mit hilfe von
abgeordneten ins parlament zu kommen
scheitern leider
[Musik]
ach da ist ja ex minister tiefensee beim
zigarettchen vielleicht kann der was tun
ist eigentlich ein bodenloses unrecht
also dafür sind sie da mal sind auf die
straße gegangen
das höre ich zum ersten mal es war nicht
unmittelbar das thema 89 ob die heute
show in den bundestag zu den sitzungen
darf aber das muss man wirklich noch mal
anschauen wieso eigentlich nicht weiter
wenn sie mögen ja leider haben wir nie
wieder was von ihm gehört
andere handeln da bin ich nicht
zuständig wäre nicht der hausmeister des
bundestages sind sie
bundestagsabgeordneter leider nicht
sondern ich bin lobbyist von dieser
wichtigen veranstalter ebene
und jetzt gehen sie da rein und wollen
mit den jungs mal ein bisschen darüber
reden was für sie wichtig wäre und
optimieren die jungs wichtig ist nicht
so natürlich wie soll eine gute impulse
bekommen
ja das wahrscheinlich sowieso nicht so
wichtig dass man dabei ist weil gott man
weiß ja wie es heute abläuft genau sind
abgeordnete ist das heute spannend
natürlich haben nicht zuhört die
opposition hat nichts zu melden
lisa sind überhaupt im parlamentarischen
alltag jetzt jetzt sieht man als sie
gerade beschrieben wie die
mehrheitsverhältnisse sind zermürbt das
eigentlich manchmal denkt man sich
überhaupt noch in ländern abgestimmt
wird versucht man die wenigen stimmen
die gegen die vorschläge der
bundesregierung sind die große mehrheit
er lässt sich da ja also es ist schon
frustrierend und nicht denke das ist
nicht gut für die demokratie und selbst
verdiente spd ja verraten uns wie es
jetzt wirklich im bundestag zugeht wie
viele abgeordnete mussten heute worüber
sie eigentlich abstimmen
prozentual auch wenn es die hälfte war
das ist es und wie läuft das dann also
wenn man es nicht weiß also dann schaut
man einfach was der fraktionsvorsitzende
einfach einen hinweis gibt der doch so
oder so oder oder ja da stehen auch wer
welche am anfang dann gibt es die holt
man sich die kärtchen der da steht schon
jemand der dann sagt rotes käppi umlauf
kärtchen war so ist also eigentlich
zugeflüstert das ist nicht offen man
kriegt auch ja ein hinweis an die büros
jetzt aber wirklich mal muss die heute
show im bundestag nach dem rechten sehen
ein nächster versuch aus
deshalb stehen sie schon lange hier
heute
ich kriege keine akkreditierung mehr
warum werden gesagt ich kann auch wenn
ich wenn ich ihnen sage dass ich nicht
von der heute-show bin sondern für den
kika 3 es ist klar jetzt kann uns nur
noch eine helfen
hallo wir haben ein problem wir sind von
der heute schon wir kommen nicht rein
frau kanzlerin haben sie vielleicht die
möglichkeit uns mitzunehmen
das wäre sehr nett die geschieht
bodenloses unrecht die pressefreiheit
ist in gefahr
die zynische geste der macht sie geht
einfach rein und wieder nichts tun
guten tag und könnte ich sie für ein abo
des heute show youtube kanals begeistern
gefälligst ein abo ab